c'est la période des nouvelles éditions
de dictionnaires frédéric après le
larousse autour du petit robert ii
contient de nouveaux mots et d'ailleurs
céline arrêtons tout de suite le
niaisage ont aussi évité de s'enfuir ou
ap et si on est fatigué on va les vaches
et dans le fond ce sont des termes donc
des mots québécois le dernier on est un
peu moins sûr mais en tout cas si le là
le petit robert le dit c'est que c'est
vrai alors le petit robert édition en
2020 ya plus de soixante mille noms et
cette édition est la 109 donc ils font
leur apparition il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'anglicismes d'ailleurs on a commencé
par exemple lorsqu'on travaille ensemble
dans les mêmes terres ouvertes et bien
on fait du coworking
c'est pas beau c'est le coworking
beaumont français voilà exactement on
parle plus seulement de donner en
informatique mais bien de da tarde
toujours dans le milieu des nouvelles
technologies par exemple lorsqu'on veut
faire défiler son écran on va scrollé
c'est pas beau ça se crowley c'est
terrible quand même le verbe scrollé
dons pour faire défiler quand on décide
de prendre pleins d'articles pour les
mettre ensemble pour faire une recherche
et pour la partager à ce moment là on
fait de la curation de contenu dont
contento rishon
c'est étrange mais c'est comme ça on va
vers un numéro de comique on va dire
c'est donc un numéro de stand-up mais
oui c'est maintenant permis c'est dans
le petit robert
quand on va voir une bande annonce de
film avec qu'on attend depuis très
longtemps
on parle ici de teasers et c'est comme
ça qu on le prononce en france selon le
petit robert
beaucoup de sport également qui font
leur entrée on parle ici bien sûr du
crossfit
si on parle de la course à pied est bien
tous ces jeunes gens ce sont des runner
regarder comment ça s'écrit c'est assez
étonnant comme on n'arrête pas le
progrès par contre il ya des mots qui
sont anglophones mais qui on parvient à
trouver un équivalent français c'est le
fait que nos c'est de l'intox donc c'est
comme de l'info c'est comme de l'intox
donc on met tout ça ensemble par exemple
les bobos vous savez des bourgeois
bohème et bien lorsqu'ils vont prendre
d'assaut un quartier
on parle ici de boboïsation et puis
quand on parle de nourriture ça fait
aussi partie de la société
les nouilles ramen le
le soba aussi qu'ils sont en train de le
petit robert le procès cole mousseux
italiens ou encore la baignoire où l'on
vend des béliers est la preuve que le
français est une langue vivante
il s'enrichit au rythme de l'actualité
mais voilà par exemple les gilet jaune
mais il ya plusieurs terres autour de ça
d'abord on parle ici de lanceurs de
balles de défense pour disperser la
foule cette entrée dans le petit robert
la loi anti-casseurs également on parle
aussi de trans partisan long qu'on sait
plein de gens qui se rassemblent autour
d'un thème ou encore look l'ocrha si ça
c'est le gouvernement par la foule le
gouvernement par la multitude donc c'est
vraiment le reflet de la société dans le
fond les dissuader je connaissais pas le
bruit rauque racing o'clock rassis merci
frédéric sont toujours intéressants plus
fascinant de voir ça en effet